hey there glad to be with you sometimes
we uh do these uh these cold opens you
know this is the last week of free mug
Club month so uh if you want this to
continue we do encourage you to go and
sign up but I want to take an
opportunity to talk about something here
um I know oh look at this I just want
height uh
people often talk about mental health in
this country and they only do it when
either celebrity dies or there's a
shooting and it's thrown around like a
political football
and it's very generalized and in meeting
some of you this weekend there's one
person in particular
um who discussed with me that you know
this show is has helped this person and
thank you to that lady whom I spoke with
at uh
I'll just say it quick trip it wasn't
racetrack
um maybe you want to take a second to
talk about this we talk about mental
health it's often very generalized and
what people will often say you'll see
whether it's on CNN or somewhere this
they say you know don't be afraid to go
get help and by the way that still
stands just to be clear you should get
help help is good by the way it's the
red tide I'm sick here today in case
you're wondering about my voice
uh but I also understand
that some of you out there may not know
where to go for help
um you right now may feel like you can't
afford help or
maybe you're in a rut and that first
step seems Monumental to go into an
office to meet somebody do a
pre-interview and get some help let me
tell you something I've done it I've
been getting help
for lack of a better word for for most
of my adult life
and hopefully I can impart some of that
that help here
um without you taking that first step
which I encourage you to do
first let me describe
what sometimes this feels like and ask
yourself if it's you does it feel like
some people are just wired this way
um and by the way sometimes rewiring
needs to take place and you can do it
but it's a matter of degree but for some
people out there is this you Joy is
harder maybe to come by
for you people often talk about
depression or anxiety let's put a finer
point on it is Joy harder to come by for
you as it is for some people and that's
just a fact some people aren't naturally
as joyous
for me I often experience Joy through
other people that's why I always liked
coaching more than competing it's why I
love doing change my Minds rather than
debates it's why we do the show that the
way that we do because bringing you Joy
is
kind of one of those things that for me
does help part those clouds and it
imparts a sense of purpose
um
does this describe you for me sometimes
my personal victories
don't feel as big as Maybe
they are
to an outside Observer and the failures
no matter how small feel cataclysmic
does that describe you
is that what you're dealing with okay so
if you haven't gotten help yet
let me tell you what I do believe is the
biggest help and has been the biggest
help for me uh by far even though these
are just some steps not a solution and
the show is meant to be helpful meant to
actually in a tangible way in a
quantifiable way help you live your life
I'm completely confident the steps I'm
about to outline will help everyone not
cure everyone but help everyone and at
the very least Do no harm they're not
capable of doing harm and just for
reference yes there are longer books out
there that will help you more in depth
Jordan Peterson's 12 rules for life
fantastic this is not a Panacea or
replacement but this is how I can best
distill
and offer I guess that first rung on the
ladder it's three things
again if this describes you number one
your overall health nutrition physical
activity sleep if you haven't even tried
that let alone dialed it in do that
first okay before you take a pill and
I'm not saying that there's no
appropriate scenario to take a pill dial
in your physical health it will help
everyone
and with that comes more importantly
structure and discipline to achieve that
which brings me to number two I want you
to try a 60-day challenge here
this isn't a meme it's not owling
nothing like that it's not Tide Pods I
want you to try 60 days
doing these things your mental health
meaning your physical health your diet
your exercise your sleep and I want you
to change your mind to a mindset of get
up and do it anyway
okay try it for 60 days switch your
mindset to that of sound simple
but do the steps required to do this to
get up and do it anyway don't feel like
getting out of bed get up and do it
anyway
don't feel like going to the gym get up
and do it anyway don't feel like calling
your mom which you know you owe
get up and do it anyway
the Same by the way applies to the rest
of these if you don't feel like taking
time to contemplate to recover uh to
plan
get up and do it anyway for 60 days try
that and then I want you to combine this
with I've talked about this before but I
think it's important and worth
reiterating
number three gratitude and I don't mean
this like some Pinterest quote
uh I get it everyone has their cross to
bear
for some of you right now watching
listening it's worse than others
some of you have had some tough breaks
too
but every day and I do this through
prayer often my prayers are simply
giving thanks
I want you to actually
go through this mental exercise not just
say oh I'm thankful what do you have to
be grateful for
start do you have a roof over your head
are you able to feed yourself every day
do you have children that you love do
you have family that you love
do you have a good friend do you have
one good friend
and sometimes it's hard for us to
identify the blessings that we do have
when we're in a rut and no one
understands that more than me it's not
lost to me if you find yourself in a
rough bind I want you to do this picture
a world in which you remove even the
small amount of comfort or Goods that
you have if you're watching or listening
to this let me ask you
what would your life look like if you
couldn't
something simple if you couldn't afford
a phone tablet TV
internet
whatever it is that you use to enjoy
this do you have children
there are people out there whose
children right now have been kidnapped
never to be seen again I cannot imagine
anything worse watched a film this
weekend where that took place made me
sick to my stomach
probably the worst fear I can imagine is
that not you are your children safe are
they even in a country where they
largely can be safe
maybe you don't have kids
what if your best friend right now your
one good friend was just diagnosed with
terminal cancer would that change your
life
will that change your life
are you grateful that that's not the
case today
and I go I know these there are
different severities to this but if you
can imagine in any way something
important to you right now being
Stripped Away
and that can happen to any of us at any
given moment would you appreciate it
more
because then if you do you not only
start to focus but Elevate the things in
your life that you appreciate you start
to Value them and then you tend to
create or at least recognize the other
things of value in your life part of
this was inspired by the fact that yes
it's this red tide sick it's not the
worst that I've had worse than covet for
sure that was a walk on the park but
when you're sick you ever notice it's
almost impossible like to to think of
anything else you know you have a
headache throat body aches whatever it
is all you can think about is your
inability to do things that you would
normally do in your day-to-day life
just yesterday night I was thinking hey
remember breathing
that was great
remember when I could breathe without
all this yeah breathing was a lot of fun
then once you recover you ever
experienced this the rebound effect you
feel like King Kong maybe you notice
your strength in the gym it feels like
those weights are Sailing sailing out of
there maybe it's your mental acuity but
there is that rebound effect but to you
right now if you're not sick right now
how often do you say to yourself man
isn't it great to not be sick I have so
much energy
an ability relatively speaking or do you
take it for granted
see gratitude is not just about
recognizing serious issues that need
addressing
or your improvement
but but that sickness rebound I'm
talking about
I'm talking about feeling and thinking
that way every day before it stripped
from you preemptively create your own
rebound effect not after so no I do not
have all the answers that's not what
this is about I hate it when people go
on Instagram and say just one more rep
whatever that's not what this is
but if you are looking for some answers
just for some improvement for 60 days
try these three things one take care of
your health
to get up and do it anyway switch your
mindset to that and three list what you
are grateful for what you appreciate as
often as you can do it and then after
that hopefully you go get some help
because life gets better things get
better
and yes you cannot control everything
that's absolutely true
but there are things you can control
right now to make your life better
60 days start now immediately try it
love you on with the show
I don't know what to say
really
it all comes down to today now either we
heal
as a Mud Club
or we crumble we're in Progressive hell
right now gentlemen
believe me
and we can stand around
and get the kicked out of us
oh we can claw
hallway
back into the light we can climb out of
hell
no I can't do it for you
[Music]
I mean I look at all these young mug
lovers faces
and I think
I'm at every wrong choice
a late 20 30 year old Sky could make
them oh yeah
I pissed off
all the social media Giants I pushed
away
every Hollywood agent who's ever
represented me
you know when you come out
as a conservative
things get taken from you I mean that's
a part of life
but you only learn that part
people start calling you a Nazi
and you find out
that life
is a game of inches
[Music]
and so is my club
they're trying to shut us down
the inches we need are everywhere around
this month and this my club we fight
we tear ourselves to Pieces we throw
ourselves at super videos we change
minds and we even make
because we know when we add up all those
Mud Club ballots and all those Minds
change that's gonna mean the
difference between winning or losing I
need a weevil now as one mug Club
a week at band
that's individual
that's my club guys
that's all it is
[Music]
now
what are you gonna do
join my club today
or die
as individuals
foreign
[Music]
delicious that's not going to solve this
Red Tide though what's going on with my
throat I don't think I don't think the
red tide is doing many favors uh glad to
be with you
a lot of opens we have a lot to get to
today uh riots in Chicago oh I know what
you're thinking this is a rerun I've
seen this no no this is live new ride
you can bring up CNN there see nothing
up our sleeves it's new riots it's just
it's new Chicago it's a new branding
effort
um something else too we've talked about
this for a while and what's funny is
actually I'm like my ears are so blocked
up right now that like nothing sounds
right in my ears oh you sound fine do I
sound normal yeah you sound like you're
on in the Mario level underwater uh
that's a long time ago and we were
actually suspended from YouTube for the
title uh of it um that they're coming
for your kids the trans uh the lgbtq AIP
well now it's very clear you always need
to ask yourself what would the left do
what would Democrats do not what happens
nationally what happens when they have
power completely unfettered you see
what's happening in Washington state and
the bill now that is going through you
know went from the state house was
amended now it's going back through it
looks like it's going to pass
uh is as evil as it gets it's as evil as
it gets and it is
[Music]
thank you
I think we're all gonna die
that was your weekend it's possible well
we all die I was fool around with a chat
GPT and I was like this is this is this
is way more than a Furby yeah I'm doing
well apparently you're not though we're
all gonna die yeah apparently I mean
eventually when nobody gets out of this
game alive no exactly that's the thing
it's all a game oh by the way tomorrow
on the show we have Jim Brewer oh on the
show this is the of course you know the
last month of free monthly monthly.com
mug club last week sorry the free month
club month so you're sick we'll give you
a pass you can give me a pass uh and
then we have in third chair actually
here today as uh pops Crowder how you
doing sir I'm doing great you mentioned
Jordan Peterson and I thought did I
forget to make my bed
took me off my game mom doesn't make the
bed she was in it
we're gonna make it with her in it I
mean you can your side Saran wrap her to
the pillow At Any Given Sunday uh clip
yeah would Jamie Foxx be an actual
football player
not at all his head was below the Shelf
level of the
changing area you could pick some guys
that can you know actually look like
football players like Garrett yes yeah
Garrett Garrett fit better than any of
those yes he did quarter black did hey
my question of the day by the way to you
is what would you do uh if your
significant other came out as trans what
would you be phobic
I don't know that I don't know that
plays into the vows how does that play
into vows there Gerald uh Christian
theology
I believe it mentions it's somewhere
near the back yes
I think there's an out clause yeah
somewhere and for those and uh we have
more on my clip today we have hipster
hobo we have quip of the week and uh of
course if you join mug Club you know you
get all of Nick depaolo's show and more
content coming and you you said you're
fine that's not true pop scratter you
were the one who gave me this you were
sick I didn't give you the Red Tide
though no kissing what's going on I just
got rid of my lozenges I just read oh he
he had a visit with a Dalai Lama oh yeah
that's right we have seven plus one on
the Dalai Lama um because he likes uh
having sex with kids oh wow so I mean I
said he likes it and sound like Buddhism
at all well so before any of that uh
last week now non-binary artist Sam
Smith uh did a whole demon uh fat trans
thing in his uh tour de force
performance
okay where to go there is
that's Sam Smith
that's Sam Smith that's awful
he looks like Boy George A Boy George
that's Sam Smith yes do we have a side
by side Sam Smith was a good looking
Chef he got pretty rough looking oh oh
my goodness the Queen of England now
ah he's dead by the way
it's Camilla yeah it really isn't now it
really is like a physical disease
leftism it really yeah it changes you we
should do a before and after we've got
uh Riley here we should do like if she
went down the left were you know oh yes
yeah absolutely no I don't want to do
that because all of you in the comments
in in the chat you know Riley she was
obviously the lovely late in the
California video you're meant to be
complimentary but you were largely
committing sexual assault and she's
married yes yes and she's showing
yourself even the compliments are
disgusting that is Sam Smith she got
great reviews in that though she did
really good she got disgustingly great
reviews that's the problem you know what
I love about that I didn't hear a lot of
people cheering I heard some let me see
it again he had to uh let me see it
again are you sure yeah one more time
you stuck
I mean there's some by the way there's
no choreography or Rhythm no that's the
thing it's just like ah it's enough I'm
gonna put this on there like I think
it's enough like like Pomp and
Circumstance the costume speaks for
itself that's all shock without the
textual yeah come on some theater here
it's a performance just go like Macho
Man it comes
[Music]
listen brother nobody more much
that guy inspired me when I was a kid
like what is this this is a real thing
mine was the Von Erics I thought the
Aaron claw actually worked oh really
yeah it doesn't yeah no that's the
problem I got into I tried to do the
claw and then got knocked out no really
well there are Asian martial arts that
thinks yes it actually works exactly
exactly I have Denmark what does that
mean means I got
[Laughter]
you kicked my ass there's a reason for
weight classes
there's a reason for weight class is
little real road work
a tourniquet on his biceps to pump him
up no that was Ultimate Warrior oh yeah
that was the ultimate that was Ultimate
Warrior Macho Man ready Savage was
fantastic hey by the way it's a live
show Monday through Friday 10 a.m
Eastern just so you know don't worry
about notifications because they don't
work on YouTube uh anyway let's just get
into I guess let's get into Chicago
riots if you see I should let you know
we have the YouTube dump button we had
to hit it in median truck today if at
any point if you're not watching on
Rumble head on over to rumble if you see
and hear this on YouTube
all right that means that it's still
running you can see all of it on Rumble
okay let's go to Chicago first
uh
wonderful just to skip and a hop away
from your hometown of Detroit
yeah sister city but it wasn't a one
trick pony though like Detroit right
yeah I don't think we're allowed to say
sister anymore sister city yeah it's
just a it's a non-binary city it's a
city it could be a chick it could be a
guy in any given day oh yeah the step
City yes
so on Saturday night hundreds of teams
uh teams teams teens teams of teens
swarmed downtown Chicago for a good
old-fashioned burn down the city
one
oh sorry
that's international news we're not
doing that right now here's the footage
from the riots in uh Chicago who can
never get anything right by Design
[Music]
wait for it
wait till it becomes World War Z
watch they start running toward the
camera
oh at that point you run away
foreign
by the way the one thing that makes
everyone their scatter
gunshot that's the one thing they make
sure that you can't have in Chicago I'm
not saying go on the street as a
vigilante I'm saying to protect your own
house as it gets looted and burned right
A lot of people watch this and they go
hey they're out there they're rioting do
you take into account that people can be
in buildings that are burned that happen
with the riots do you remember the story
of the man who knew that his wife and
daughter were in an apartment that was
being burned in the fire department
couldn't get there it's not just about
these people needing space to destroy
and by the way there's nothing new in
Chicago the new mayor is going to do
exactly what the old mayor did there is
no way for it to improve that's the
theme of today by the way what does the
left do when left completely unfettered
not within the systems of checks and
balances we see it with Detroit we see
it with Chicago yeah I was in Chicago
actually
um gosh going to a Notre Dame game in
October and we were at a light in 15 20
30 motorcycles should have run the light
no no no here's the thing it turns green
for us they come through doing wheelies
and everything else not one single
person honked not one person tried to
pull out like there was this degree of
like if I do something here that's wrong
yes there's no one here to protect me no
of course not yeah it was very and if
you protect yourself you'll be the
criminal I'm like Michigan Avenue like
up by the lake like it wasn't like some
small hole of Chicago well this is why
how do you get that many people to do
that out there and they're not concerned
about the cameras they're running toward
them they're saying hey did you get my
close-up they are they are doing this in
plain sight there's a boldness that
comes with that as a result of policy
this is just 10 days after the soft on
crime uh new mayor elect uh Brandon
Johnson
was announced as mayor uh soon to be
mayor here's what he said he said it is
unacceptable and has no place in our
city good statement however
it is not constructive to demonize youth
who have otherwise been starved of
opportunities in their own communities
no no no
they just burned down their own
communities
opportunity to run around and Riot and
loot I just saw it it is not productive
constructive to demonize youth
I disagree
I think it's incredibly constructive to
demonize youth I think it's incredibly
constructive to punish youth to
discipline youth especially I think it
might even be constructive to try them
as adults
I don't know is that just me comment
comment below like if you agree if
you're there on YouTube or hit the
rumble button remember how remember when
I was a kid I used to discipline me
there pop scrotter from time to time The
Wooden Spoon used to make me pick it if
I picked the small one you got a bigger
one anyway which almost seemed like it
wasn't really a fair decision I wonder
why the Democrats have starved them of
opportunities yes good point I don't
know what policies could they possibly
have in place by the way I just want to
know uh would it be okay to go to the
store owner whose store was looted and
just say well these are just kids guys
I'm sorry they didn't have opportunities
in their Community yeah is that going to
heal that situation it's not
constructive I don't know if anybody was
hit by the gunfire but maybe the person
that was shot can you ask them that as
well what they mean is it's not
constructive to demonize well first off
so what they're saying it's not
constructive for you to say bad things I
think it would be constructive for you
to protect your house and home in your
business without I mean use of force
just to be clear you're not advocating
going out and committing violence again
but I certainly think that you're
entitled to use Force to defend yourself
Most states recognize that and that
includes violence yeah people are
burning down your store but they don't
even want you to say bad words so but
it's about this is all about this is the
theme here that has been going on for
the last several you've heard me say
it's about turning law-abiding citizens
into criminals and criminals into voters
can you imagine anyone left or right in
the 60s or 70s seeing that saying well
you know what really though it's not
constructive to demonize them even back
then they had to fame people in Democrat
Party like well they shouldn't Riot
right I mean who are they blaming that's
what I want to know and well take a wild
guess what were they blaming they've had
control of these cities without
opposition for Generations well I think
they're they want to buy the votes yeah
for the people that have been starving
them of opportunities in their
communities I I will the mayor elect
blames the police as seen by the fact
that he was a major proponent of
defunding the police of defund the
police quote prior to his election the
president of the United States the
former president of the United States
I'm sorry President Barack Obama uh took
it one step further as well and and
basically said that the the the effort
of the defund police movement lost an
audience because of of that
um
that slogan I guess is what he's calling
it which which I don't look at as a
slogan it's actually it's an actual real
political goal
he backtracked and said no no I didn't
mean defund the police here but what
about when you said it's not a slogan
you actually think it's a political goal
meaning defund the police he said stop
that it's not constructive to demonize
me for what I said that was last week
sir but that's in my past yeah that's in
my past
[Laughter]
don't worry it's mayor ain't nothing
going to change ain't nothing gold chain
we'll compare his policies and by the
way in other news for the city uh
Walmart permanently closed uh four
Chicago stores sure on Sunday saying
that the stores have lost tens of
millions of dollars because you can only
have great drink on a five finger
discount for so long
sugar water purple
remember that and don't forget this is
Ronnie mostly uh uh while talking about
this so the same thing applies here yes
who they blame they blame the cops who
do they blame they blame Walmart
here's uh Ronnie Mosley uh um he's uh I
guess from the 21st Ward Ronnie Mosley
Alderman elect from the 21st ward of
course I was not familiar with him
before he said this dumbassery
blamed Walmart for the closures it is on
the corporate citizens that come into
our community and ravage our community
okay and Walmart you should be
absolutely ashamed of yourself
you are the reason
that our communities lack the investment
that they have you hear that lady
stand before God or a shame before God
like okay wow Walmart should be ashamed
before God really you want to take it up
with the Walton family I just I just
watched World War Z of criminals in the
middle of your city you mean everything
isn't free in Walmart it was the walking
dreads
they should not lock up the fox said
Walmart they should not lock up the hair
color they should not lock up the
shampoo at Walmart where are we gonna
get a razor butt lotion
what
so here's the question how did Chicago
get here they think they want and you
can comment below spoiler alert they
want you to blame the police they want
you to blame Republicans they want you
to blame also remember when they blamed
guns coming in from Indiana
wouldn't Indiana
well it's out of Gary have the problem
that Chicago does all the guns are
coming in from Indiana ruined in our
state you looked have you looked at
their state shut up there's barely a
city near you in Indiana like South End
is the first real place you get to it's
all about abdicating personal
responsibility and anyone who's fooled
by the by this shell game at this point
I'm sorry guys you really are morons if
you're in Chicago and you think you can
blame this on the police you think you
can blame this on Donald Trump uh I
think you're probably past hope so let's
recap the Chicago policies in 2020 the
Cook County D.A uh Kim Fox drops charges
on 29.9 percent of felonies wow that was
compared to the previous D.A of 19 which
by the way is still pretty damn High
that's very high 2022 Illinois became
the first state to eliminate cash bail K
2022 foot pursuit was not allowed for
anything besides um violent felonies and
arrests in Chicago are at historic lows
which by the way is a really hard metric
because you can't really take into
account how many people would have been
arrested who aren't being arrested I
don't know if that's a hard number had
counted those videos that we just showed
you and said that should have been
arrested rest arrests so 2005 arrest
rate was 31 2021 arrest rate 12.3
percent and uh the homicide rate uh is
the highest and it's been in over 20
years in Chicago
those are great policies and the
policies from this new mayor are the
exact same what is it it's defund the
police and now he says will not really
defund the police restructure police
yeah it's blame corporations uh it's
more gun control right he wants red flag
laws the funny thing is when you look at
the policy of this new mayor who says
I'm going to change a city change what
it's the same thing as the previous
ain't nothing going crime you can keep
that vote for me the only
difference is Walmart
gone mother vote for me people like ah
he's talking my language you want jobs
at Walmart no not what and haven't they
just matched Detroit where 80 of all
murders go unsolved I don't know if it's
80 I know it's very high and again
that's a hard metric because they just
say is this an unsolved murder they go I
don't know let's just not file that one
okay
we'll leave it what's the point of all
these Awards it was a homeless guy screw
it that's the evidence what is it what
is this like when he looks back on the
past he's like at least I'm not a
lesbian is that it like because that was
mayor lightfooter's like okay that's you
guys are yeah otherwise yes vote for me
because I don't look like a catfish
everyone else is the same no catfish
eyes no more Beetlejuice
then they told him like you won he's
like you're bullshitting my portfolio
don't grow
[Laughter]
it is a crap hole Chicago it used to be
a cool City it's not it's not even safe
right now in tourist spots it used to be
Ferris Bueller's Day Off that was
Chicago this wonderful place you can go
hang out now you don't trust me and
about to be uh yes about to be passed by
Dallas as the third largest city in the
country ah dropping like a stone Dallas
is growing like crazy good
you know it used to drop a stone is that
Sam Smith
how much is a stone it's a stupid
measurement system I'd be like okay I
weigh too 225 so that's like 100
something kilograms and then
2.7 Stones it doesn't sound very good
someone lost weight it's like oh my gosh
look you're withering away yeah how much
you lose I lost point zero one stone a
stone is 14 pounds okay that would be a
lot more I was off no yeah way off I
don't know I don't believe it okay
smash the rubber button if you're
watching oh by the way
good for you 14 pounds who picked that
measurement I don't know it probably
doesn't matter it's an increment who
cares well it's hard to measure why I
don't want to be rounding decimals for
weight
we're more offended by that than she
could just round my height down I'm like
six foot two and three quarters I just
say six two instead of six because I
don't want someone to like put me up in
the measuring stick like oh you said
you're six three so I just say 16. fine
what if it was Stone I know stone is
weight the point is SNL is a propaganda
Wing
yeah so this brings us you see in
Chicago if the left has their way
unfettered see Detroit see San Francisco
and I want to use SNL here as a jumping
off point because it really has become
this is propaganda by the way and this
is why comedy is largely dying on the
networks and that'll bring us to
Washington what's happening with the
Trans bill which is I don't want to say
trans Bill what's happening with the um
child abduction Bill let's call it that
child abduction bill the bill to abduct
your children from you if you don't put
them on Purity blockers or give them a
sex change so
let's start I apologize my voice is
gross does this make any does it make me
soundwhat sexy though no a little bit no
not to any of us
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
it's reducing SNL's First non-binary
cast member it's critical name
Journey
which works if you're making fun of it
that's something to celebrate
well as you know I've been wanting to
come to update and talk about trans
people but I have for a much longer time
than that wanted to fly down from the
ceiling we wanted you to identify
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thanks
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thanks
assistant
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
two three
[Music]
four five
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
power that's what is most concerning
it's not what do they do when they're
checks and balances
what do they do when those don't exist
so guess who the checks and balances are
it's you we're going to continue this
conversation as well as hipster hobo by
the way uh this is the last month you
can hear my voice
[Music]
Apollo's show also Monday through
Thursday at 5 pm and more shows coming
down the pike yeah if you don't join up
guess what none of this exists and uh
YouTube wins so we'll see you that right
now we'll see you there if you're it's
free so you can watch it on Rumble
or you can just you know you can watch
it on Mud Club yeah but uh YouTube
all right first are we still on YouTube
We Wish we've been dumping
constantly on YouTube so as long as we
know how much of the show is on YouTube
as long as we can pick whichever
bathroom we've done all right YouTube
piss off
[Music]
thank you